[Música]
bueno aquí estábamos muchas gracias por
haber unido al club le doy la bienvenida
esto es extra de la charla muy
agradecido que estén todos acá y que
disfruten esta jornada que realmente me
parece histórica para el club la guerra
de malvinas me enseñó a ser generoso
solidario egoísta me enseñó a hacer
pasivo calmo pero también vehemente me
enseñó a hacer cosas que no tenía
pensado hacer en mi vida pero
situaciones que se planteaban momentos
que se planteaban hacían que uno tuviera
que resolver tuviera que plantearse qué
hacer sin saber muy bien las
consecuencias sin encontrar un final
deseado para esa consecuencia sin
embargo uno lo hizo y trató de ayudarlo
de la mejor manera posible sí sin duda
la guerra de las malvinas cambió la vida
en un sector grande de nuestra comunidad
en un sector de jóvenes de 18 o 19 años
que fueron parte de la guerra sin duda
les cambió la vida
una de las consecuencias de ese cambio
grande en cada uno fue el estrés
postraumático que significó participar
de una guerra pero bueno todo eso lo
vamos ir desarrollando a lo largo de
este tiempo que tenemos para contarles
un poco cómo fue la guerra por aquel
tiempo la incertidumbre de lo que pasaba
en la guerra era lo que más me
preocupaba cuánto tiempo iba a durar
cómo íbamos a desarrollarnos cómo nos
iban a atacar distintas cuestiones que
tal vez con 18 o 19 años uno no tenía
muy definidos esa era una de las
principales incertidumbres o principales
problemáticas de aquella época del año
82 año 82 que no se encontraba con un
país gobernado por una dictadura militar
un gobierno de facto
no estaba muy bien visto por una parte
de la comunidad tenía serios problemas
con organizaciones de derechos humanos
no tenía muy clara la economía del
manejo y cómo llevarlo adelante y que de
buenas a primeras 12 de abril recuperar
las islas malvinas
a encontrar un poco cómo fue mi guerra
tengo que contarles algo también de cómo
era yo antes de eso había hecho la
escuela primaria y secundaria con tigre
siempre andaba al límite de hacer una
macana era transgresor era divertido y
todo ese conocimiento todo ese contenido
lo fui trasladando a lo que fuera del
servicio militar obligatorio
y por suerte lo pude trasladar a la
guerra y por suerte bueno los que me
conocen saben que algunas veces en mi
equipo te algo pero trato de mantener un
equilibrio entonces bueno esa estaba acá
en tigre la escuela primaria la escuela
secundaria el crecimiento deportivo y
social en este club fueron fortaleciendo
me a los 13 14 15 años de una
personalidad de una forma de ser que me
permitió después valorar mucho más lo
que hacía lo que había aprendido había
que esperar el servicio militar en
aquella época el servicio militar era
como un orgullo para las familias que su
hijo varón el tío te contaba historia el
abuelo te cuenta victoria entonces el
servicio militar era una alternativa de
la cual se está paga con el número bajó
con acomodo o con algún problema de
salud por suerte mi salud funcionaba
bien acomodo no tenía pero ni loco y
jugado con el número claro
mi número del sorteo es el 342 y en ese
año se salvan hasta el 3 40% 6 por 2
números por 2 números como cambió mi
vida imagínense que sea con 341 de
verdad peor que yo porque por un número
cambió su vida totalmente bueno
esperamos ese año para hacer el servicio
militar y la pregunta al público en
general es ahora saber qué saben ustedes
o que se acuerdan del año 82 lo que
tiene más de 45 vieron que ahora se dice
lo que tienen canas los que peinan canas
o los que no tengan nada
sin hacer referencia a ninguno entonces
los que tienen más de 45 años que se
acuerdan del año 82 porque también hay
que ponerse en el concepto de cómo
estaba el país como estaba el mundo que
que imaginaban de la guerra que hablaban
con sus papás con sus tíos con sus
abuelos con esos vecinos que se la
sabían toda era una locura entrar en
combate con gran bretaña era una era un
disparate combatir contra la otan
escuchaba en radio colonia se acuerdan
los grandes lo que era radio colonia nos
enterábamos todo lo que pasaba y en la
prensa nuestra agradecida miraban a tc
se acuerdan de korso gomes y casan seu
hemos logrado hablar y era todo un circo
tal vez lo que se hablaba y los que
tienen hoy 2025 que saben de la guerra
como la haga escuchan como la ven como
la sienten se meten en las redes
averiguar y tratan de participar los
videojuegos son tan reales como la
guerra superan
el otro día en una charla me decía un
chico cuántas vidas tenías vos en la
guerra
por un lado me dio una gracia razonable
decir bueno jajajaja pero por otro lado
dije es donde estamos parados si creemos
que con un juego tenemos más de una vida
así que bueno esa es una parte del
inicio de esto para darle el sentido a
lo que vamos a charlar resultó ser
sorteado dentro del servicio militar el
número 342 me va a quedar así cruzado en
la cabeza y nos encontramos ya en el
servicio militar hacemos todo el año 81
servicio militar y esa dictadura militar
ese gobierno de facto se mete en la
guerra de malvinas recuperamos nuestras
islas festejo alegres contentos y muchos
preocupados nuestro regimiento que era
parte de la décima brigada se traslada
al sur y yo como siempre era un
personaje yo decía nos vamos de viaje de
egresados claro terminamos la colimba
viaje de egresados terminamos acá lo más
bien igual viaje realizado cuando cayó
la primera bomba no sabíamos dónde
meternos pero bueno eso lo llevó como
contenido de mi forma de ser para poder
haber pasado
no digo una buena guerra pero sí haber
sido distinto a otros que tuvieron
grandes problemas y los tienen hoy en
día entonces bueno el regimiento de
nuestro es movilizado hacia el sur y de
buenas a heras
madrugada del 13 de abril de 1902 bajó
de un avión y estamos en las islas
malvinas imagínense hoy que tenemos
muchos jóvenes 19 años bajándose de un
avión en un lugar de terror con frío
oscuro sin ninguna referencia salvo una
historia de una pista que había hecho y
pf hace unos años que ya me acordaba el
colegio pero bueno imagínense ustedes
los más jóvenes bajándose de un avión en
una pista para ver qué pasaba nos
trasladamos por adentro de la isla a
nuestra posición era puntualmente en el
monte dos hermanas ahí teníamos que
cuidar una determinada zona éramos una
compañía helitransportada y ahí van
pasando los días del 13 de abril al 30
de abril aproximadamente son los días
que estamos sin hacer nada charlamos
entre los soldados nos ponemos en
contacto
nuestras fuerzas se van desplegando
alrededor de la isla y vamos sabiendo
que la flota británica se va acercando y
ahí nos preocupamos un poco más empiezan
algunas cuestiones de nerviosismo que
vamos a hacer van a venir nos van a
venir estamos preparados no estamos
preparados
algo que quiero dejar bien en claro y
que durante muchísimos años se al
respecto desde la preparación de los
soldados yo les puedo asegurar después
asegurar más allá del servicio militar
no nos enseñaba a matar gente oa ser
héroes
el servicio militar nos instruía de
forma de resistir determinadas
situaciones en la paz pero realmente
cuando vino la guerra el servicio
militar fue útil por eso de alguna
manera yo quiero dejar en claro este día
y en este momento que fuimos bien
instruidos ningún ser humano le puedo
asegurar puede sobrevivir a la
intemperie de las islas malvinas
2s es donde sabe que se les va
terminando la comida donde sabe que la
ropa no se les repone en donde sabe que
no tiene posibilidad de cierta de volver
vivo si no tiene instrucción y es básica
la instrucción para una escuela para una
empresa para lo que sea si uno no tiene
un protagonismo un rol un desempeño un
ángulo lugar en 10 15 días se desmadra
todo y terminábamos todo entre nosotros
matándonos entonces yo quiero dejar en
claro y a muchos les puede pesar pero no
es defensa desde lo que es la mitad sino
de la instrucción hacia el ser humano
ese trabajo que se hizo para dejar
formadas personas para que tengan su luz
y su desarrollo esa instrucción no fue
permitiendo desarrollarnos en nuestro
lugar obviamente nuestras bajas fueron
muchas
nos encontramos en combate directo con
los británicos en el monte dos hermanas
luego en el monte table donde dos
lugares muy fáciles de identificar
cuando uno se mete en informática con el
tema de la guerra nuestros soldados
tuvieron el valor de defender esos
lugares con su cuerpo y con su sangre
muchos han dado su vida por esas tierras
y todo esto también apareció al correr
de los años por la aparición de internet
y demás cosas que nosotros o sea ustedes
o el público en general se fue enterando
de lo que los británicos contaban de la
guerra hay siempre una anécdota que dice
si queréis saber cómo te fue la guerra
pregúntale a tu enemigo porque fue muy
bueno el desempeño de muchos soldados
acciones heroicas pilotos
y artilleros ametralladoras que han
quedado registrados en la bibliografía
británica lamentablemente la nuestra no
sé por qué pero no quedó pero de a poco
vamos tratando de malvinizar de volver
al lugar que algún momento debemos haber
tenido más allá de los años pasados y
hablando de años
25 años después de terminar la guerra yo
vuelvo a las fuerzas armadas al ejército
a un alto fíjense el tiempo cuando uno
habla de replantearse cosas de cambiar
cosas 25 años me llegó a mí volver al
ejército a un acto después de 28 años
gracias al esfuerzo de la municipalidad
de tigre y al regimiento 6 donde yo hice
el servicio militar y con el cual fui a
máquinas hacemos un acto a que hacer acá
en la paloma en la casa misma del
soldado juan domingo ni verger él muere
en combate él durante tres o cuatro
horas retuvo a guardias escoceses y
galeses con una ametralladora el tipo es
reconocido por los británicos y nosotros
tardamos 28 años en hacerle un homenaje
por suerte encontramos lugares como les
digo la municipalidad 2010 el regimiento
y la familia de juan domingo tuvo el
acto en su puerta misma su su hermana su
padre su madre ya había fallecido y eso
a mí me hizo muy bien me reconfortó
porque fuimos parte de todo ese acto
28 dije 36 años después esa familia sabe
que su hijo o su hermano está enterrado
malvinas por el gran trabajo que hizo la
cruz roja internacional con forenses
argentinos y forenses británicos que
hasta el momento y en un término de tres
meses pudieron identificar 105 cuerpos
imagínense 105 familias que la
multiplicamos y serían de 2 mil personas
porque tienen hijos primos cuñados amigo
lola 2500 personas hoy saben que esos
cuerpos están enterrados en malvinas 37
años después o 36 más o menos así que
bueno esto lo abordó como referencia al
tiempo como el tiempo se lleva a las
cosas pero en algún momento hay que
cerrarlas ya mí se me está yendo el
tiempo entonces bueno después de toda
esta historia de volver al continente de
volver a casa de encontrarme con mi
familia que me permitió recuperarme de
muchas cosas de encontrar a los amigos
acá en el club de insertarme nuevamente
en toda trabajar a la municipalidad hace
36 años que tenían una municipal
y fíjense si me relaciono a la gente
sale la idea de volver a malvinas y acá
me queda casi nada de tiempo y vamos con
todo
vuelvo a malvinas porque igual o válidas
porque tengo que volver porque es mi
tierra es nuestra tierra es nuestro país
los isleños dicen para que las reclaman
si no vienen entonces uno vuelve igual y
una vez igual y dos veces y volví tres
veces ya voy por la sexta vez y me
encanta el viento me encanta el humo de
las cocinas de la turba que queman y me
encanta ir por la calle diciendo malas
palabras en español y que los tipos de
miren y me encanta todo eso entonces
cuando uno va volviendo y huévar
trayendo cosas de ese viaje y que traigo
que quique llegó alfajores un souvenir
entonces un día de los niños se me
ocurrió traer algo
cuando ustedes entraron les dieron un
sobre que no lo tenían que abrir
entonces cuál es el compromiso a partir
de este momento vayan acomodando en sus
en sus mochilas en sus cosas y vamos a
abrir el sobre jugó que poco que me
queda
eso que tiene no hay ustedes y yo lo
quiero compartir y creo que lo tenemos
que sentir y creo que es parte de este
compromiso de este tiempo nuestra
soberanía no se negocia nuestra gente
que dio la vida merece nuestro respeto
y lo que tienen ustedes sabor en sus
manos es tierra de las islas malvinas
[Música]
aguante 15 minutos se me terminó el
tiempo pero bueno con esta tierra quiero
hacerlos parte a todos ustedes de esta
gran gesta que tuvimos los ciudadanos
que fuimos a la guerra estoy orgulloso
de haber ido a la guerra y el eterno
reconocimiento y el honor a todos los
que dieron la vida seiscientos cincuenta
y 649 soldados y todos los que
lamentablemente no pudieron con la
posguerra que si bien volvieron no
encontraron lo que merecían no tuvieron
lo que merecían y lamentablemente por
cuestiones que no eran ajenas al mundo
no pudieron recuperarse y hoy no están
con nosotros así que bueno los invito
los convoco quiero que sean mis
cómplices y que esta tierra parte de
esta tierra sea parte de su vida y que
todos los días que nos levantemos la
toquemos es nuestro territorio son
nuestras islas y tenemos que defender
nuestra soberanía no entreguemos las
malvinas
[Aplausos]